[Music]
the starving orphan seeking a second
helping of gruel the spinster wasting
away in her tattered wedding dress
the stone-hearted miser plagued by the
ghost of Christmas past more than a
century after his death these remain
recognizable figures from the work of
Charles Dickens so striking is his body
of work that it gave rise to its own
adjectives but what are the features of
Dickens's writing that make it so
special
Dickens is fiction brims with
anticipation through brooding settings
plot twists and mysteries these features
of his work kept his audience wanting
more when first published his stories
were serialized meaning they were
released a few chapters at a time in
affordable literary journals and only
later reprinted as books
this prompted fevered speculation over
the cliffhangers and revelations he
devised serialization not only made
fiction available to a wider audience
and kept on reading but increased the
hype around the author himself
Dickens became particularly popular for
his wit which he poured into quirky
characters and satiric scenarios his
characters exhibit the sheer absurdity
of human behavior and their names often
personify traits or social positions
like the downtrodden Bob Cratchit the
groveling uriah heep and the cheery
Septimus Chris Farkle Dickens set these
colorful characters against intricate
social backdrops which mimic the society
he lived in for instance he often
considered the changes brought about by
the Industrial Revolution during this
period the lower classes experienced
sorted working and living conditions
Dickens himself experienced this
hardship as a child when he was forced
to work in a boot blacking factory after
his father was sent to debtors prison
this influenced his depiction of the
martial sea prison in Little Dorrit
where the titular character cares for
her convict father prisons orphanages or
slums may seem grim settings for a story
but they allowed Dickens to shed light
on how his society's most invisible
people lived in Nicholas Nickleby
Nicholas takes a job with the
schoolmaster Wak furred Squiers
he soon realizes that squares is running
a scam where he takes unwanted children
from their parents for a fee and
subjects them to violence and
deprivation Oliver Twist also deals with
the plight of children in the care of
the state illustrating the brutal
conditions of the workhouse in which
Oliver pleads with mr. bumble for food
when he flees to London he becomes
ensnared in a criminal underworld
these stories frequently portray
Victorian life as grimy corrupt and
cruel but Dickens also saw his time as
one in which old traditions were fading
away London was becoming the incubator
of the modern world through new patterns
in industry trade and social mobility
Dickens is London is therefore a
dualistic space a harsh world that is
simultaneously filled with wonder and
possibility for instance the Enigma of
Great Expectations centers around the
potential of pip an orphan plucked from
obscurity by an anonymous benefactor and
propelled into high society in his
search for purpose pip becomes the
victim of other people's ambitions for
him and must negotiate with a shadowy
cast of characters like many of
Dickens's protagonists poor pips
position is constantly destabilized just
one of the reasons why reading Dickens
is the best of times for the reader
while being the worst of times for his
characters Dickens typically offered a
clear resolution by the end of his
novels with the exception of the Mystery
of Edwin Drood the novel details the
disappearance of the orphan edwin under
puzzling circumstances however Dickens
died before the novel was finished and
left no notes resolving the mystery
readers continue to passionately debate
over
Dickens intended as the murderer and
whether Edwin Drood was even murdered in
the first place throughout many
adaptations literary homages and the
pages of his novels Dickens is sparkling
language and panoramic worldview
continued to resonate today the
adjective Dickensian often implies
squalid working or living conditions but
to describe a novel as Dickensian is
typically high praise as it suggests a
story in which true adventure and
discovery occur in the most unexpected
places although he often explored leaked
material Dickens is piercing wit never
failed to find light in the darkest
corners
ted-ed is a non-profit if you value our
work please consider supporting it on
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]